It may sound strange, but as liberal, I do
believe in American exceptionalism.
Due to our democratic ideals and personal
freedoms, America is a unique and special
country in the world.
You may remember back in 2009 when President
Obama said he didn't really believe in American
Exceptionalism, saying "I believe in American
exceptionalism, just as I suspect that the
Brits believe in British exceptionalism and
the Greeks believe in Greek exceptionalism."
In and of itself there's nothing wrong with
Obama's general idea here in which each individual
country is filled with proud people who believe
their country is unique and special in the
world.
Actually, if this idea fuels people to build
a better society they can be genuinely proud
of, then fantastic.
Of course by the same token, this nationalism
could also push otherwise good people to believe
they should have a sway over the world or
influence other nations because they are morally
superior.
Over the eight years of Obama's presidency,
he walked back his statement, and did actually
say that America's exceptionalism was unique.
For me, there is an additional reason for
American exceptionalism which goes beyond
just our democratic ideals and personal freedoms.
Of course we aren't the only country in the
world to share in those ideas.
It is also the additional piece America is
a country of immigrants, a country of people
from all of the world who came here to make
a better live for themselves.
We are a nation built by people whose ancestors
often came here with nothing, and who worked
hard to build a better country and life for
their children and their children's children.
While we certainly aren't the only country
to welcome immigrants or build a solid middle
class, there is no other nation on Earth that
more people from more countries have come
to live and prosper because of the pursuit
of happiness.
This doesn't mean everyone can come here and
we can have open borders, but it does mean
that if you come here legally, you will be
given the same chance a natural born citizen
has.
Even today, as we live in a politically fractured
society and many will tell you things have
never been worse, the the truth is things
have actually never been better.
Now of course I don't mean that for every
specific person or every specific job or industry.
Times change and so do people and economies.
But as a whole, America has done an incredible
job of welcoming so many diverse people, having
us all share in the American dream while at
the same time all being able to keep traditions
and practices from our unique cultures.
As our economy changes over the next few years,
we the people have a massive job of changing
along with it.
In an age where supermarkets will be automated
and driverless cars will replace truck drivers,
it will be more important than ever for us
to change with technology.
The world doesn't stop for anyone or owe you
anything, you have to adapt to a changing
world.
And in these moments of change is when America
has been at its best.
Our system, built on the idea that it's your
job to pursue your happiness is the reason
that more people still want to come to America
right now than any other country on Earth.
I always find it ironic that so many people
who rant and rave about how evil America is
are the same people who demand we let anyone
in here.
Why would anyone want to come to such an evil,
unfair and oppressive society?
Of course this is nonsense and they know it.
There's a reason that people don't leave America
in droves, even the celebrities who said they
would leave if Trump was elected have some
how managed to stay here.
For the record, I'm pretty sure Canada is
happy it didn't have to take in most of them
anyway.
I mention all this because for all the goodness
here in America, we obviously still have some
work to do.
Every society has work to do, which is why
the people peddling utopia are frauds and
liars.
In America though, almost every generation
has fought to expand rights to other people,
not to limit them.
That's how women got the right to vote, that's
how we freed the slaves, that's how gay people
were allowed to marry and that's how whatever
will come next will arrive.
As for that work we have to do, I think a
lot of it has to be done on how we can come
together, not rip each other apart.
I'm a firm believer that most of us want the
same things in life.
We want to work a decent job, eat some good
food, have some sex and go on vacation now
and again.
Most of us aren't racist homophobes secretly
plotting against each other and trying to
push our way of life on everyone else.
This is somewhere which no matter your political
leanings we can all come together.
Yes, some of us are from big cities, some
of us are from small towns, some of us had
ancestors who arrived on the mayflower and
some of us just arrived yesterday, but the
only way this all works is if we all bend
to fit American ideals of freedom of liberty,
not if we demand the system bend to us.
My guest this week is comedian Trae Crowder.
Trae is known as the liberal redneck...apparently
they do exist.
His comedy is a blend of showing liberal elites
that rednecks aren't all backwards hicks and
showing rednecks that liberals aren't all
evil socialists.
It's almost as if we should judge people as
individuals, not as groups.
I feel like I've heard that somewhere before.
The middle of this country for a long time
has been the brunt of jokes and the easy way
to make fun of anyone who thinks differently
than people in New York or LA.
As someone who has only lived in New York
or LA, I've never subscribed to this way of
thinking and have tried not to mock people
just because they talk differently or haven't
evolved on some of their social views the
second that I have.
Whether your Democrat or Republican, straight
or gay, black or white, native American or
new immigrant, this country belongs to all
of us and it needs all of us to continue to
make it better.
That's the thing with exceptionalism, it take
an awful lot of work to keep up.